hey guys i'm jeff mcdonald it is the
fourth of mud and you're tuned into
games what news first up decided to may
have been leaked or it may not have but
let's suspend disbelief for a second a
sequel suggesting image landed on all
games beta and teases the potential logo
for the new game it also says in 3 2014
will be where the game is officially
revealed and also consists on the
hashtag darkness of tibia real or fake
and are you holding out for the stealthy
sequel let me know next up I have
something nice to say about the xbox one
so maybe people will stop calling our
sony spot probably not turns out of the
twitch app for microsoft's shiny new
console broadcasts at a higher quality
than its ps4 counterpart I read a user
called rot jran major nelson's plants vs
zombies stream through the twitch
analyzer and apparently while the ps4's
resolution came out at 960 x 540 the
xbox one did so at 1280 by 720 both
platforms broadcast at 30fps though
other stuff the xbox one will let you do
is archived personal streams not
broadcast audio from party chat and show
streamers chat and viewer statistics
without them being displayed on the
strings next up if you can manage it you
really ought to be Batman and now you
can be Batman again thanks to the
announcement of Arkham Knight Rocksteady
are behind to the fourth installment
which will be coming to ps4 xbox one and
pc sometime in 2014 game informer
confirmed the news today and we were
lucky enough to actually get some
details on the game it'll be set in a
way bigger Gotham City with wider
streets to facilitate you racing down
the road in your crazy awesome Batmobile
oh yes I said Batmobile apart from that
super cool addition a bunch of
well-known baddies will be making
appearances including penguin to face
Polly Quinn and of course scarecrow as
rumored earlier laughs stuff remember
how I said the PS bull was gonna do
pretty well out of its Japan launch well
it turned out
totally came to fruition it's just past
six million sales sony announced the
news alongside a whole mess about the
statistics including that three hundred
and seventy thousand units have been
shifted in japan and three million ps4
owners have signed up to playstation
plus they've also captured 100 million
shares though as mum Justin theorizes
quite correctly in our news article half
of these are probably just people who've
mistaken the share button thought the
select button let me know in the
comments or on my twitter if you have
used all would use the share
functionality to post up your gameplay
videos online that is everything that
I've got be today but be sure to join me
again for more newsy stuff tomorrow